hier auf diese Wiese soll ein
Containerdorf für 500 geflüchtete im
ostseeviertel von Greifswald dagegen
regt sich deutlich Unmut und Protest im
ostseeviertel Leben etwa 6400 Einwohner
die Meinungen zur geplanten
Flüchtlingsunterkunft gehen auseinander
die Leute müssen ja irgendwo bleiben und
würde würden wir in der Lage sein wir
werden auch froh wenn wir irgendwo
unterkommen könnten wir haben hier
unsere Autos zu stehen und man weiß ja
nicht Kriminalität bei den Leuten ist
aber immer so ein bisschen Angst vor
wenn hier irgendwas passiert wir kriegen
gar nicht zurück es sind ja nicht nur
ruhige so wie wir hier Ukraine haben die
sind wirklich sehr sehr ruhig mit den
kommen wir auch wunderbar klar wir haben
keine Probleme damit ne aber
wenn so viele Leute auf einen Haufen
sind
ich denke mal nicht ich bin dafür Leute
zu helfen
aber es mussten vernünftiger Weg sein
also ich würde keinen Stich lassen wenn
ich Platz hätte dann könnten bei mir
auch noch drei einziehen Jürgen Liedtke
engagiert sich ehrenamtlich als
Vorsitzender der ortsteilvertretung dass
die Stadt hier eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft plant hat er erst
vor wenigen Tagen erfahren die Anwohner
und auch er führten sich überrumpelt da
verlange ich einfach vom vom Obi dass er
oder das wünsche ich mir auch noch auf
alle Fälle schnellstmöglich
schnellstmöglich eine
Bürgerinformation macht wie er zu dieser
Entscheidung gekommen ist und wie er das
bewältigen wird viele Anrufe besorgter
Anwohner muss er derzeit annehmen er
selbst ist gegen die Unterkunft an
diesem Standort denn sie seien hier
überfordert
die Überbelegung praktisch der der
Sportvereine der hier auch der
Kindergärten und und und und wie soll
dann die Integration hier im Prinzip
durchgeführt werden also das das ist
nach meiner Meinung für diesen Container
also für diese Größe überhaupt nicht
machbar
im Viertel gibt es viel Protest während
einer Sitzung der ortsteilvertreter in
einer Schule des Stadtteils versammeln
sich 500 Menschen draußen demonstrieren
unangemeldet gegen das Containerdorf
darunter auch 20 gewaltbereite und
rechtsradikale
sie stehen 50 Gegendemonstranten
gegenüber
der Oberbürgermeister braucht
Polizeischutz um die Sitzung zu
verlassen Stefan Fassbinder verurteilt
das aggressive Verhalten einzelner
insgesamt ist es natürlich nicht in
Ordnung dass Leute so auftreten dass sie
so einen Druck ausüben ja nicht nur auf
mich sondern durch diese ganze Stimmung
ja auch z.B auf die Mitglieder der
ortsteilvertretung das sind
ehrenamtliche Mitgliedern in ihrer
freizeitpolitik machen bundesweit gehen
Menschen wegen der aktuellen
Migrationspolitik auf die Straße
rechtsextreme unterwanderten diese
Proteste immer wieder warnen Experten
das Wichtige ist aber vor allen Dingen
dann dabei dass man immer klar den
demokratischen Protest und den
extremistischen Protest eben voneinander
unterscheidet und das ist dann die
eigentliche Herausforderung im
politischen Diskurs der Expertenrat
friedliche Demonstranten sollten sich
deutlich abgrenzen von extremistischen
Gruppen
es ist davon auszugehen dass
Rechtsextremisten nur auf die
Gelegenheit warten dass es solche
Proteste gibt damit sie nämlich dort
sich dann anschließen können weil ihr
Anliegen ist es ja immer nicht am Rande
der Gesellschaft zu stehen sondern ihre
Anliegen in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
hineinzutragen der Landkreis Vorpommern
Greifswald rechnet mit 3000 geflüchteten
in diesem Jahr Unterkünfte gibt es keine
mehr der Druck ist hoch auf
turnhallensolle möglichst nicht
ausgewichen werden heißt es von der
Verwaltung Greifswald als größte Stadt
im Landkreis biete gute
Integrationsmöglichkeiten aufgrund der
Infrastruktur der medizinischen
Versorgungsmöglichkeiten aber natürlich
auch gucken wir danach dass wir den
Verwaltungsstandort hier in Greifswald
haben damit dann auch kurze Wege für
diejenigen bestehen die häufig zu uns
ins Amt müssen
Ausländerbehörde Asylbewerber
Angelegenheiten das ist immer ein Thema
wo wir wo wir dann Kontakte zu den
geflüchteten auch brauchen landrat
Michael Sack fordert vor mehr Geld vom
Bund wir brauchen die nötigen
Hilfsmittel dazu insbesondere was die
Integration Sprachkurse anbelangt aber
eben zunehmend auch Integrationslotsen
weil wir im Ehrenamt immer weniger
Menschen finden die dazu zur Verfügung
stehen Greifswald sei eine weltoffene
Stadt sagt Oberbürgermeister Stefan
Fassbinder er fordert eine sachliche
Debatte über Migration und Integration
die Zuwanderung sieht er als Chance das
Hauptproblem die Hauptgefahr für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
Ostdeutschland sind die vielen
Arbeitskräfte und gleichzeitig
diskutieren wir nur darauf wie Leute die
zu uns kommen Sie vielleicht wieder
loswerden also die Diskussion müsste
ganz anders geführt werden wir müssen zu
einer legalen Einwanderung kommen die
unsere arbeitskräfteprobleme löst die
die illegale Einwanderung reduziert
zumindest geordnete Verfahren werden das
heißt die Debatte muss ganz anders
laufen wir müssen die Chancen sehen und
die vernünftig gestalten
das Containerdorf im Greifswalder
ostseeviertel könnte kleiner werden als
zunächst geplant die Stadt will jetzt
weitere Grundstücke prüfen damit mehrere
Unterkünfte für maximal 200 geflüchtete
gebaut werden können